durant ces deux jours les quelques 90
mille salariés de la régie renault
retrouve le chemin des bureaux et des
chaînes c'est la rentrée tôt ce matin
billancourt nos reporters patrick boiter
et claude sicard son talent est évalué
en quelque sorte l'état d'esprit les
salariés de renault alors que la cgt
distribué des tracts appelant à la
mobilisation dans le quart de sa
quinzaine d'actions
6h ce matin les slogans de la cgt sont
encore frais sur la chaussée les
affiches tout juste collé les
distributeurs de tracts déjà à l'ouvragé
réunion
va bien
c'est une rentrée chaude qui s'amorce
havrais
c'est la rentrée que décidera le
personnel pour l'instant l'avenir de
billancourt rien n'est joué tout va
dépendre de l'action du personnel et
nous allons faire en sorte avec lui me
mettre en échec plan de casse du
gouvernement et de georges besse ce
matin beaucoup de salariés inquiets
semblait prête à suivre la cgt demande
tout si on va pouvoir regarder l'autre
est normal qu'on pour le boulot les gars
pour leur envoyer leur cours normal vous
voici que la cgt a eu raison d'agir
ainsi ah je coure qu'être maman
il faut que billancourt il reste des
encours quoi comme il a toujours été moi
ça fait trente ans que je vis ici
on n'a jamais vu ça la première fois ci
les usines ferment cause de grève tout
le monde sent obligé de suivre
on s'oblige et il
après avoir pris la température dans les
ateliers la cgt consultera ses militants
demain pour décider d'une éventuelle
action un meeting avec le personnel est
déjà prévue pour jeudi matin
précisons qu arnaud doré dans les autres
centres de la régie nationale la rentrée
a été considéré comme calme ce matin
monsieur bergeron vous avez suivi